-I saw a new report that says
that people should not rake
all the leaves out of their yard
because it's actually better
for your lawn's health.
So, I think, with that in mind,
it's time to say goodbye
to my rake.
Rake, are you there?
-A lifetime of autumns together
and this is how I find out
I'm fired.
-Come on, rake,
don't think of it as fired.
Think of it as retiring.
You can now
do anything you want.
-Man, I want to rake leaves.
Fall is my whole personality.
-Look, your future
is what you make it.
We'll see you in the spring,
when it's time
to clear the flower beds.
-You're right, Jimmy.
Hey, we had
some good times, though.
Remember high school?
[ Laughter ]
I used to hang out with you
and your friends.
Watching you guys play hoops,
hoping you'd take a rake break.
[ Laughter ]
Who was that guy that used
to pour out half his Gatorade
then fill the empty half
with Yoo-Hoo
and call it Gator-Hoo?
[ Laughter ]
Ed Zipperton.
Man, that guy was cool.
He pantsed me at prom
while I was dancing alone
to "Lady in Red."
It was the part where it goes...
[ Laughs ]
♪ The lady in red ♪
-Yeah, it was.
-♪ Is dancing with me ♪
♪ Cheek to cheek ♪
[ Laughter ]
Then, shoop!
That's the sound
of my pants going down.
And the worst part is, my pants
got caught on my prom boots.
Yeah, the tuxedo rental man
at the mall tricked me
into paying extra for something
called prom boots.
[ Laughter ]
They were just Dr. Martens that
he spray-painted bright green.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, wait!
I forgot.
I'm supposed to be doing
the voice of a rake.
[ Laughter ]
Not reciting
a page from my diary.
-This has been another edition
of "Making James Read Lines
He's Never Seen Before."
[ Cheers and applause ]